[Applaudissements]
agathe quel est votre plus grosse honte
quelle était votre goût ma plus grosse
honte j'étais au lycée et c'était la
première fois où j'allais enfin pouvoir
aller dormir chez mon amoureux de
l'époque nord ou qui avaient me
présenter à sa famille il s'appelait
charles charras oui ça me parle de quoi
[Musique]
alors il a laissé ses parents il
habitait je sais pas on était au lycée
enfin donc j'arrive chez ses parents
donc je m'étais un peu stressé pour la
première rencontre quand même et les
présentations se passe très bien on dîne
tout se passe très bien
hélas bien le moment d'aller au lit
ouais donc moi j'étais tout excité à
l'idée de dormir dans la dans la chambre
de mon petit copain
non mais un décalage j'avais 15 ans j'ai
tendance à contrôler des choses ou bien
bas c'était l'épauler première fois quoi
c'était l'âge de mes premières fois oui
[Applaudissements]
m
ses premières amours ses thèmes et tout
mais preneur parce qu'un bel animal a
fait l'amour à 30 beinheim
c'est donc ouais bon voilà et donc on
arrive on monte à étages pour aller se
coucher et là sa maman me dit agathe
jeter préparer la chambre d'amis ah
ouais bon très bien sûr aidé en fait
c'était la chambre qui était mitoyenne
celle de mon amoureux n'ont allumé une
porte qui communiquaient entre les deux
elle avait déplacé les meubles de la
maison pour bloquer les portes genre toi
empêcher qu'on se rejoignent donc dans
l'hyper mal à l'aise je n'avais pas non
plus j'aurais respecter bref finalement
la nuit arrive les parents vont se
coucher on finit par se rejoindre
oui et on s'est fait grillé et j'ai
jamais aussi nombreuses depuis février
je t'adore commun aux pays bas par la
maman car l'étendue du travail est en
train de faire quoi
on n'était pas non plus dans des
positions à brac avec laquelle était
ténue n'ont généré
[Applaudissements]